bello e tutti ragazzi pervenuti a questo
video sono fa vj prima di cominciare
questo video prima di cominciare vorrei
fare una premessa non lo faccio mai
quindi scusatemi se per una volta mi
prendo un secondo però volevo veramente
a ringraziarvi particolarmente avere una
cosa che sta succedendo in questo
periodo quando è uscito il film come noi
non siamo attori insomma non la
cinematografia non è mai stato il nostro
obiettivo quindi io non farò la torre in
futuro il film è un progetto e sono
progetti più che altro indirizzati a voi
non ha un pubblico grande perché
ovviamente il pubblico abituato al
cinema di tutti i giorni ma è
indirizzato più che altro a voi che ci
seguite che ci conoscete il nostro
obiettivo era quello di accontentarvi
nel miglior modo cioè emozionarvi in
generale insomma fargli piacere quello
che abbiamo creato in questo anno per
ciò che mi sono io non mi aspettavo
mai mai ma veramente mai mi sarei
aspettato questo stupendo riscontro da
parte vostra se tutti che mi scrivete
dio mi sono emozionata dio mi vorrei la
parte ii perché tutti mi dicono fa rai
teche intera p2 c'è chi se l'hai visto
due tre volte ragazzi e sono veramente
contento che riesca a parlare [ __ ]
sono contento che vi sia piaciuto
basta tutto qua sono veramente contento
che vi sia piaciuto così tanto so che
molti di voi ancora non ha potuto
vederlo che magari non hanno avuto tempo
insomma nel caso sappiate che questa
settimana è l'ultima poi non ci sarà più
perché è stato due settimane poi non lo
trasmettono più quindi se volete vederlo
avete tempo comunque fino a domenica che
tra l'altro io farò anche gli ultimi
incontri 15 vedremo domenica e sabato è
insomma ragazzi grazie grazie di cuore
veramente io ripeto so che a livello
cinematografico in generale che poi ha
ricevuto anche un sacco di critiche ma è
giusto perché fa parte del gioco quando
fai un film poi non essendo attori non
siamo neanche cene che potessimo
pretendere però cazzo vedervi tutti
tutti così contenti sto parlando di chi
ci segue e vittoria è veramente vittoria
per noi
cioè vittoria non è una persona nel
senso che abbiamo siamo contenti cad io
sono contenti altri non lo so magari se
ne sbattono il cazzo meglio sono
fottutamente contento ovviamente scherzo
vi lascio al video volevo solo farvi
questa premessa perché ci tenevo da
lorenzo neanche da famiglia e ci tenevo
veramente tantissimo a volte non
riuscivo a dormire dalla contentezza
cioè io sono non ho rifatto neanche
letto qualche roba grazie di cuore vi
lascio al video scusatemi se sto fatto
sta premessa schiavo per tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono farisei e
ci siamo di nuovo video figo video figo
è una reaction ragazze di orari action
horror streep e la serie dei fancazzisti
anonimi che iniziata circa una settimana
fare siccome sono stati così gentili da
sei anni come primo partecipante a
questa sfida horror
lo vedremo insieme perché ancora non
l'ho visto mi sono cagato addosso ma
tanto proprio voluto che fosse una
sorpresa appunto per vederlo con voi a
farla reaction se le fronti l'ex carlo
sia la visione a schermo intero con
cuffie in una stanza buia va perfetto
era meglio di così
[Musica]
ma sì però è la madonna con videogame il
battello bellissimo oddio no va bene che
io faccio questa cosa però calmi o road
trip perfetto è partito bene amadò in
casa si fa vigeva all'inferno five 0
formica che finora ci siamo si è questo
che lo riconosco ragazzi o al che aveva
una cosa non dovete mettere una i ragni
ogni sei tu accordo stretto che cosa ci
ho addosso io saremo a contatto
telefonico con te inviare la tesi cosa
diremo noi le indicazioni ciao ragazzi
io ero imbardato tipo bear grylls una
roba perché la bellissima
ok a posto sì esatto 66 metterla una
torcia in testa complimenti fai la cosa
più bella di tutto quanto è che sono
bardato è tutto marcio la maglietta jolo
della serie se devo schiantarmi non
faccio il video già ragazzi accaduto
grazie vale è stato orribile
questo sono io è solo perché non riesco
a essere serio quando faccio le cose ma
ci manca caricati sulla tua destra alle
tue spalle c'è una piccola stanzetta
tutto chiaro dentro dovrebbe esserci una
bevanda energetica
io ragazzi qua pensavo di dovermi
infilare nel coso tipo oddio che schifo
cieli di finirla a denver in un altro tv
e entrare nella stanza lì a destra se li
troverai stella non mi sto ca che hanno
in mano per carità di dio sono
tranquillo sembra tipo outlast ragazzi
uguale a ci sono chi ppm vero ct poco i
battiti cardiaci
ah ecco la bretella che bello devo farlo
dovrebbe essere lui inserire che va bene
dove lo inserisco un uomo il carburante
io veramente io devo versare è stata il
cazzo r2 d2 così star wars mi si vede
che il figlio ragazze ha funzionato si è
riattivata casa roba funzionano sono
programmate per dare indicazioni
io voglio solo dire questa è stata la
cosa più [ __ ] ma allo stesso tempo più
non sense che abbia mai fatto in tutta
io io vedevo lui me lo ricordo vedevo
lui che mi seguiva mi guardava così era
una foglia
erona era solo una foglia ragazzi se
pagati in mano per una foglia
ecco beh non è che chi mi accompagnava
pò vende anche fra cagare in mano
antonio aveva beccato una ragnatela sì
ecco le hanno viste qui scusatemi
ecco io come cazzo faceva trovare delle
pile che sono in mezzo alle piante in
mezzo alla calma merda e poi in posa era
impossibile trovare questa era veramente
impossibile perfetto porca [ __ ] oscar
dategli un oscar subito lanciategli un
premio oscar
da adesso inizia la parte figaro che
cazzo affaccia la faccia di valerio
ornato da bruno orarie silenzio
praticamente sto contemplando le
inferriate perché ho sentito dei bei
rumori e tipo mia nonna quando rotta
adesso adesso inizio a corti perché
faccio tutto di corsa di spoiler mi sto
pagando ufficialmente addosso questa la
voglio vedere come è venuta la che non
lo so ma inizia a correre comunque gli
occhi unico lo so di aver corso come un
allegro col bechei la è sempre betteloni
ok nota che a correre paratia corre
anche se non rispondi
vorrei bpm stiamo morendo
qui non c'era nessuno
ma c'è ancora qualcuno di sotto cosa a
mio zio
adesso ce l'hai fatta hai trovato tutto
il necessario e sei pronto per andare
nell'edificio c dove si trova
all'ingresso dei sotterranei e vi
assicuro ragazzi che sono molto meglio
di questi sotterranei giuro dai andiamo
ai sotterranei ragazze far fuori era
anche una bella giornata dopo dentro che
era una merda sta entrando il guardalo
lì come s'atteggia complimenti
porca [ __ ] che freddo nella stanza che
ti troverai di fronte ci sono delle
colonne e delle botole in una di queste
botole dovresti trovare la mappa dei
sotterranei
la mappa è fondamentale lorenzo perché
nei sotterranei non potremo più essere
in contatto a 6 ecco ci siamo dio c'è il
ragazzo dovuto infilare le mani in una
botola dentro un schifo
sento dei rom oggi non sono per niente
terrorizzato nostro solo guardando di
uomini e donne pc ragazzino ma che roba
c'è un ragazzo distrutto dalla vita
propria ma lei messo a cagando sotto
stai zitto
ho preso delegata una corda bene che
cazzo fa ho detto su una bambola se
questa chiave si
è in questa chiave ti serve per aprire
portato la strada ma [ __ ]
sei stato tu no no seriamente non si
scherza
non ho capito una roba che è successo è
successo niente
andiamo avanti ovviamente la bambola era
attaccata una corda e quando io l'ho
posata qualcuno ha tirato la corda e la
bambola s'è mossa io mi son cagate in
mano però non avevo capito che ci fosse
qualcuno chi c'è una cassetta che potrai
aprire con la chiave cosa ho attaccato
al muro va bene il miliardo chiama
sonntag attivano anche adesso quella
lanciata la starda sì l'ho trovato il
contenitore porca [ __ ] strappa di mano
sinceramente mila ragazzi ste cose negli
individui succedono mai che si toglie la
scarpa però a me succede se mi son
cagati in mano qui guardando il video
adesso figuratevi quando quando stavo
facendo c'è stata una roba non ve lo
posso neanche spiegare orribile sì ho
trovato di starlight sede pronti per
scendere nei sotterranei chiare ad
inserire la parte bellissima nei
sotterranei da questa la parte è la
parte più bella perché i sotterranei
sono è la parte più horror di tutto il
video secondo me è bellissimo termica
puntano però era battery dunque chiesto
per entrare i sotterranei ok e questa
estate che posto sono i sotterranei e
ragazze parecchia roba e brutte
no no passardi non ci voglia è finito
così a c'è la parte 2 ha detto no danni
ci posso credere affatto la parte 2 è
vero ma aveva anche detto mi sono
dimenticato io ragazzi vi prego no no no
no un grazie è stata allora mi spiega
accendiamo le luci che porta ai vani sto
pagando in mano grazie io ve lo dico
dovevo fare assolutamente la reaction
perché c'è questa particolarità che a me
piace l'onor vederlo poi mica go in mano
però mi piace un po come quando metti il
peperoncino sulla vasta che poi ti
pizzica pro ti piace una volta nella
vita volevo fare un'esperienza del
genere allora ho detto va bene partecipo
a questa cosa e non avete visto il
seguito ragazzo è stato epico veramente
epico voglio vedere la seconda parte ci
son rimasto di merlo sapevo che era
diviso in due parti ma non mi ricordavo
non me lo ricordavo
spero che ai video vi sia piaciuto è
stata reaction del secolo perché cazzo
rivedermi in nei panni di sembrava di
giocare un videogame nella vita reale
insomma è stato epico giuro vero che ha
visto vi sia piaciuto se volete vedervi
video integrale perché io l'ho fatto che
non li taglio ovviamente ve lo lasci
descrizione perché è video dei
fancazzisti grazie ragazzi per avermi
invitato a questo incredibile
questa cosa bella proprio adesso per il
mio compleanno ne organizziamo un altra
posso della festa facciamo un rossi
spero che vi sia per cento come se i
ragazzi video piaciuta soprattutto è non
mi piace anche a faccia di facebook con
il videoton restizioni già avvertiti se
ci vediamo passo biblico